Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Chiara Anna Gagliardi
Io devo assolutamente, adesso,
esprimere le mie emozioni.
Perché sto male.
E perché sto male?
Sto male davvero.
Sono una studiosa del dolore,
quindi dovrei essere capace
di parlare di questo dolore.
Perché sto male?
Questo mi risuona, perché
sono state dette delle cose,
dunque sto male sia per la mia paura
- del fallimento, naturalmente -
che è legata al mio desiderio
di grande successo
- ma al top, come diceva
la speaker americana.
Però ho tanta paura,
ho tanta paura perché finalmente TED-
io ci avevo provato, in America,
a proporre la mia candidatura
ma nessuno aveva detto sì,
e invece qua mi ritrovo inaspettatamente,
qua, a TED: mi tremano le gambe,
avevo fino adesso un male allo stomaco,
un pugno, proprio.
Guardavo la Valeria, 14 anni,
sembrava molto più tranquilla di me!
Eppure io ho fatto delle conferenze,
ma non ce n'è: questa
è una opportunità di successo
e mi cago sotto, scusate.
(Risate)
Meno male che vi fa ridere:
a me non fa ridere,
però meno male che fa ridere.
Io sono stata tossicodipendente
dai 15 ai 20 anni.
Eroinomane, per la precisione, quindi
mi facevo le iniezioni in vena di eroina,
e per procurarmi i soldi
per comprare l'eroina
sono stata delinquente
e mi sono anche prostituita.
Ecco, io volevo dire
queste parole qui a TED.
Quando mio padre mi ha visto
per strada, con un cliente,
mi ha fatto sapere
che non mi voleva più vedere
se io non smettevo di farmi.
E grazie a questo ultimatum
smisi, entrai in comunità...
... e mai più mi drogai.
Però tutti i problemi di autostima,
ovviamente, di vulnerabilità,
che mi avevano portato all’eroina,
perché l'eroina mi faceva sentire
forte, importante,
perché prendevo la peggiore droga,
tutti quei sentimenti comunque
rimasero, ovviamente.
La comunità non era sufficiente:
quindi iniziai una psicoterapia
- 12 minuti, è possibile? -
Quindi rimasero, iniziai una psicoterapia
che mi permise di capire
che io avevo bisogno di essere vista.
Questo è fantastico:
avevo bisogno di essere vista,
avevo bisogno di toccare il fondo,
avevo bisogno di attirare
l'attenzione dei miei, naturalmente,
ma anche di toccare il fondo.
Nel 19...
ecco, sapevo che mi sarei dimenticata
di mostrarvi le slide:
questa è l'epoca delle droghe.
Infanzia da bambina invisibile.
Ecco, nel 1986 conobbi
un fotografo italiano, milanese.
Ci innamorammo e io mi trasferii qui,
perché io son spagnola,
non l'ho detto:
mi dicono forse
se sono sarda, ogni tanto,
ma mi sento mezza milanese,
24 anni in questa città!
Mio marito, quello che fu mio marito,
poi non più - però - era fotografo.
È fotografo,
già lo sto ammazzando.
(Risate)
E lui - io lo guardavo lavorare
e lui fotografava le persone
e tirava fuori una forza
e un carisma nelle persone
che di persona non si vedeva.
Allora io, affascinata da questo
mezzo pazzesco che è la fotografia,
per prima cosa girai
l'obiettivo verso di me,
il primissimo autoritratto, nel 1988.
Fu allora che avevo ricreato
uno sguardo,
quello sguardo profondo
di cui avevo bisogno
e che prima io chiedevo gli altri:
ma adesso, primo passo
verso l'indipendenza,
me lo davo a me stessa.
E continuai a fotografarmi.
Dopo alcuni anni di autoritratti
cominciai veramente
a fotografare gli altri
perché gli autoritratti mi permisero
di aprirmi al mondo,
però continuavo a fotografarmi.
E nel frattempo fotografavo gli altri,
facevo progetti, divenni un'artista,
vincevo premi, pubblicavo libri
e facevo le mostre.
Finalmente avevo trovato
il mio strumento.
Continuavo a fotografarmi,
finché a un certo punto,
durante la separazione da mio marito
provai di nuovo a fotografarmi;
e scoprii che se io riuscivo
a tirare fuori
la disperazione e il dolore lancinante
che sentivo nella foto,
mi passava subito: cinque minuti dopo
cominciavo a ballare,
era come se fossi riuscita
a passare ad altro.
Ed è per questo che ho parlato
del mio dolore, innanzitutto:
perché adesso non c'è l’ho più,
adesso ho il godere
di questo pubblico che mi guarda.
(Applausi)
Quindi ho fatto della fotografia
la mia medicina.
E poi anni dopo mia figlia Yassin,
per metà senegalese,
mi chiese se poteva
fare un autoritratto,
e scattò una serie meravigliosa,
a tre anni.
E fu allora che capii
che quello che io stavo facendo
con la mia pratica artistica
poteva essere utile agli altri,
cominciai a studiare il perché
l'autoritratto fossi così potente.
E cominciai a tenere
workshop di autoritratto,
costruii il mio metodo che si chiama
"The Self Portrait Experience"
e cominciai a insegnarlo
a bambini in giro per il mondo,
ad adolescenti,
eterna adolescente che sono,
nelle carceri - questa è San Vittore;
Barcellona, un carcere
per tossicodipendenti;
In una comunità per malati di aids,
per malati terminali di aids
- Salvatore, di Pompei -
nei musei, nelle gallerie,
nelle Università,
per terapeuti,
per tutti i generi pubblici,
in modo che le persone
potessero usare il loro dolore
e metterlo nelle immagini,
convertire dolore in arte
e, permettetemi anche di dire,
merda in diamanti.
Una sorta di alchimia moderna
(applausi)
Oh… bocca secca, 6 minuti,
una sorta di alchimia moderna
perché in realtà il nostro dolore,
la nostra merda
è qualcosa che ha un potere
creativo e sociale enorme.
E questo potere
creativo, sociale, enorme
vuol dire che è
fortemente condivisibile,
- ecco qua la prova, ok? -
se riusciamo a farlo.
Quindi - ma perché l'autoritratto
è così potente?
L'autoritratto, non il selfie:
il selfie in realtà è immagine pubblica,
è creato perché noi subito
lo vediamo sulle reti sociali.
Invece l'autoritratto -
quindi il selfie è più controllato,
perché tu controlli l’immagine
che tu vuoi dare al mondo.
Mentre invece l'autoritratto no.
L'autoritratto è lasciare
che il nostro inconscio parli
con il linguaggio dell'arte,
e dica quello che deve dire
e non importa quello che dice.
Se appare un mostro, ebbene,
è uscito il mostro, finalmente.
L'autoritratto, quindi,
è la voce dell’inconscio,
però non ci etichetta,
non ci definisce,
perché in realtà noi dobbiamo
pensare a due dimensioni:
la dimensione conscia,
- perché abbiamo deciso, nella vita,
di essere più o meno così,
di fare certe cose
di non fare certe altre -
e invece la dimensione inconscia:
ma nella dimensione inconscia,
vi assicuro, noi tutti,
ognuno di noi ha il potenziale
di essere tutto e tutti,
da Madre Teresa fino ad Adolf Hitler,
con tutta la gamma in mezzo.
Lì dentro il potenziale c'è.
E il nostro inconscio ha bisogno
di esprimere, regolarmente,
qualsiasi cosa
che ha bisogno di esprimere,
quello che dobbiamo affrontare oggi.
Quindi usiamo l'autoritratto,
usiamo queste immagini
in cui noi non ci riconosciamo,
che butteremmo;
invece di buttarle lavoriamo su di esse
per stabilire un dialogo tra me e me
e così riuscire in qualche modo
a ritrovare in quelle immagini che rifiuto
- non lo fate più, di buttare immagini -
in quelle immagini che io rifiuto
io ritrovo i miei valori,
ritrovo le mie emozioni profonde,
ritrovo la mia infanzia, la mia famiglia,
ritrovo le mie radici
e ritrovo i miei bisogni profondi
che sono la base per poter trovare
la mia missione
e per poter realizzare i nostri sogni.
Queste foto che avete visto
sono state scattate
durante i miei workshop di autoritratto.
In queste foto io lascio la persona
da sola nello studio,
do delle istruzioni sulle espressioni
di emozioni e me ne vado.
La persona scatta alcune foto
e poi le mettiamo nel computer
e io accompagno la persona
a guardare in profondità quelle immagini,
e quello che succede
è che in queste foto
viene fuori questo altro da me;
ma solo guardandola anche solo 5 minuti,
il fatto di vedere questi valori,
questi bisogni e questo passato
e queste - ovviamente, questa persona
in soli 5 minuti riprende possesso
di questo altro da me e poi magari,
in un'altra sessione, un altro da me
e un altro da me e un'altra Cristina,
e un'altra Cristina e così via-
più forza, più molteplicità:
perché in realtà qual è il problema?
Questa cosa fa paura.
Fa paura perché?
Perché a scuola nessuno ci ha insegnato
che l’identità non è fissa,
che l’identità è mutevole,
che è molteplice,
che è sempre in divenire.
A scuola mancava una materia
assolutamente indispensabile: questa!
Il dolore, le emozioni,
l'interiorità umana.
Adesso guarderemo queste immagini,
questa immagine, concretamente,
e vedrete che nel lato sinistro-
il lato sinistro è il lato che corrisponde
al lato destro del cervello.
Il nostro lato sinistro
è il lato delle emozioni,
della introspezione,
è il lato del passato,
è il lato della vulnerabilità,
è il lato femminile - tutti abbiamo
il lato maschile e femminile,
e qui avevamo visto disperazione,
avevamo visto rassegnazione,
avevamo visto dolore lancinante;
ma anche una reazione al dolore,
in un sessantesimo di secondo
che era questa foto.
Il dolore, ma anche la reazione,
cioè un dire no,
non tollererò mai più una decisione, ok?
Invece l'altro lato - vi giuro,
non è photoshop, è la stessa foto-
l'altro lato invece
è il lato dell'intelligenza.
è il lato della saggezza,
è il lato del progetto,
è il lato della strategia
per raggiungere quel progetto,
è il lato del futuro,
è il lato maschile.
Ripeto, tutti abbiamo
anche quel lato: usiamolo.
E quindi, questa
è la perfezione umana:
nell'altro lato vedevamo rassegnazione;
ma in questo lato vedevamo l'opposto,
vedevamo speranza, vedevamo forza,
vedevamo una vincita.
E quindi in realtà
noi siamo perfetti così,
siamo l'unione di opposti!
Perciò quello che io vi propongo
è di dialogare con queste immagini,
di pensare a voi stessi,
alla vostra identità
come qualcosa di veramente
molteplice e ricco,
perché la potenzialità ce l'avete tutti
per fare tutto.
Dipende, come si diceva prima,
da quanta forza, impegno,
da quanta convinzione ci mettiamo,
dalla possibilità o dalla capacità
di lavorare sulle nostre emozioni,
di comunicarle,
perché se noi usiamo l'arte
che è uno strumento potente
per tirare fuori, guardare, creare
questo dialogo potente con noi stessi,
diventeremo senz'altro
più forti e più saggi.
Ma se in più noi vogliamo
comunicare questo al mondo,
come io oggi ho fatto qua,
allora acquisiamo il ruolo dell'artista,
che è colui o colei
che esprimono e comunicano
i bisogni profondi dell'essere umano
del presente e del futuro.
Grazie, tempo zero!
(Applausi)